it's hot do you like hot food no
[Music]
hi i'm kelly i'm a culinary producer
here at tasty hi i'm jeremy i'm a chef
and kelly's husband and we have two boys
together dylan and teddy and we are
about to have our third this fall
so last time we were here tasty
challenged us to see who could make the
best lunch for our son dylan and i won
and i've had the bragging rights ever
since but today i finally got the chance
to redeem myself because tasty invited
us back to see who can make the best
breakfast for dylan do you guys want to
add some steaks to this i think whoever
wins gets to choose the next family
adventure i want to go
to a really nice hotel with a pool and i
want to go to a punk rock concert oh my
god yeah that sounds that's our
personality all right let's do it may
the best man win
today i'm making a beach themed
breakfast for dylan he is a water baby
he has a water sign he's always loved
the beach and i think he's really gonna
love this so the first thing i'm gonna
make is some pancakes and i'm gonna
shape them into a sailboat so we have
some any milk we'll do this is almond
milk that's vanilla a little maple syrup
because you need it and then bananas
some oats and then some baking powder
and of course a little salt and some
eggs i love these pancakes because it
requires no whisk you can just put
everything in the blender it's whole
ingredients it's super healthy and the
kids love them
so this looks good and for easy pouring
i'm just gonna put it in a squeeze
bottle just so i can pour it easier into
the pan so i have a pan heating i'm just
gonna add some butter because i can't
make a pancake without butter dylan
loves pancakes but to be honest i don't
think i'm gonna beat jeremy this time i
make the boys lunch every day but jeremy
really does the breakfast in our house
so
we'll see so i'm gonna try to make a
pancake sailboat so i'm gonna make a
half circle to do the bottom it's cute
i'm gonna fill it in i've never done
pancake art before but i've seen it on
tik tok so that's like college
it's bubbling up top so i'm gonna flip
it hopefully it looks good hey that's
not bad so i'm just gonna cook it on the
other side probably like 30 to 60
seconds my little boat is done i'm gonna
take it out and then i'm gonna clean
this out and make the sales dylan's not
really a picky eater he'll eat like a
lot of food he's outgrown that picky
eater stage our other sun is in it right
now we're just gonna let these cook
probably like one to two minutes until
they're bubbling and then flip them over
my little triangles are done it's not as
cute as i had up here but you know what
as long as it tastes good so the next
thing i'm gonna be making is sand for
the beach and i'm actually gonna use
scrambled eggs for that crack some eggs
and then a little salt jeremy always
makes fun of me that this is the most
annoying sound he's always i think
you're done beating them
i think the secret to really good
scrambled eggs is obviously butter and
low and slow i'm just going to pour
these in here some people will like
constantly be stirring it and that will
get you really small curds but i
actually like them to kind of be bigger
softer like clouds these are looking
perfect i'm going to take them off the
heat so they stop cooking and let's go
to the next step so the next thing i'm
making is a avocado toast palm tree i've
never done this before but i need to
take some bread and cut it into the palm
leaves and then toast it so i can put
avocado on top i hope this works
i think i have to do the crust to make
it keep its shape which is fine dylan
actually likes crust so
no problem there once i put like the
avocado on it and it'll look like a leaf
this is working just stay with me guys
just
i'm just gonna pop these in a 400 degree
oven for like five to six minutes just
until they're lightly toasted my toast
is toasted now i have to cut an avocado
to perfectly fit on top of that bread
to make little leaves just gonna cut it
in half so i cut the avocado in half and
then in quarters and then i'm just going
to cut little slivers to make the palm
leaves but first let me actually put
some lemon on it so it doesn't brown so
i'm going to try to trim the toast to
the shape of the avocado and then i'm
going to cut like some little slits like
this give it the palm leaf look let me
just season it with some salt and then
look so i'm going to repeat this with
the rest of my toast and then move on to
the next step now that most of my
elements are done i'm going to work on
the final touches which is creating sea
creatures out of tons of fruit this big
boy is a cantaloupe which dylan just
started liking so for this one i found
this cute little fish cookie cutter and
i'm gonna cut out some fish from
cantaloupe okay this one where look at
the little fishy and then i'm gonna make
a dragon fruit starfish now i don't
think dylan's ever had this to be honest
i'm gonna use this starfish cookie
cutter to make some starfish look how
cute it is things like these would drive
jeremy nuts like he doesn't have the
patience to like cut things out of
little shapes maybe that's where i'm
gonna win the next thing i'm gonna do is
try to make a turtle out of a kiwi so
this will be our little body and then i
gotta cut a head and some legs here's
our little head all right to cut the
little feet so i made a circle and then
i'm just going to cut the circle in half
and make its little leg there he has
four little legs does it look like it
just to give our little turtle friend
some eyes mini chocolate chips i think
he's cute now i'm gonna make a little
strawberry crab i just cut another round
for its body i'm just cutting little
rectangles and then the little antennas
here this is definitely not what i
envisioned but we have to go with it and
i'll just add some chocolate chips for
eyes and hopefully dylan will love it i
think he's actually pretty cute so let's
make our final thing which is a sun
which i'm gonna do is slice an orange
and for the rays i'm just gonna do some
dried apricots dylan actually loves
dried apricots any dried fruit really
the last thing we have to do is assemble
it all together i'm actually so excited
to assemble this i'm going to do half
savory and half sweet so we get a little
bit of both for the savory side we're
going to do some of our eggs as the sand
and then for the palm tree i actually
cooked up some maple sausage and i'm
going to make that to the trunk by just
stacking a few up top and then we have
our avocado toast for our palm leaves
for little coconuts we're gonna do some
blueberries which dylan also loves for
the ocean on the sweet side i'm gonna
take some greek yogurt and spirulina and
dye it to get that ocean blue color last
time jeremy got eaten alive in the
comments for how much food dye he used
so i'm trying to go the natural route so
don't come for me so i'm just gonna put
some yogurt down here for our water
every morning we eat yogurt so i think
this will like draw him in and then once
he tastes everything he'll love it this
is his favorite granola and i'm gonna
put it at the bottom so it's like the
sandy bottom of the ocean i feel like i
just want to like make it a little more
wavy now we're gonna add our sailboat on
top now we gotta add all our sea
creatures so we'll put a little starfish
a little goldfish we got our sun i think
this is so cute i honestly am not the
type of mom that does this type of stuff
so when i do do it it makes me feel very
happy and excited for his reaction
sailboat needs windows so with some
banana slices on there this is art
all right i feel like i should add maybe
one more fish and another starfish i'm
done honestly i feel pretty good i'm
super excited to give this to dylan i
think he's gonna love it i'm feeling
really confident about this but jeremy
also is the breakfast king so i'm a
little nervous to see what he's come up
with let's go see today for my meal i
will be making a monster themed
breakfast because dylan loves monsters
and i will be starting with monster
muffins first we'll add our eggs dylan
when it comes to breakfast is not a very
picky eater but every other meal
throughout the day he is next we're
going to add our oats we're going to add
some cinnamon our flax seed gonna add
one banana and some spinach because
these are healthy muffins today dylan
usually doesn't eat his veggies so we
try to find ways to sneak it into
whatever we're doing we're gonna add a
little green food coloring just to
brighten it up a little bit and then
blend everything together it's looking
pretty good the color we want is there
so as we're cooking it the color is
going to die down a little bit in the
oven now we're just going to pour it
into our muffin tins and get ready to
bake them i have not made these muffins
before but based on dylan i think he is
going to enjoy them a little bit of a
risk i don't know after the last
competition i got my butt kicked a
little bit but we'll see what we can do
so the last thing i'm gonna do is add
these little candy monster eyes just to
make them look a little bit more like
monsters he's been telling me for weeks
now i'm gonna pick you no matter what
the results are so i'm feeling pretty
confident today
i know that's the one that's the one
part i'm worried about is the blind
taste test and now we're gonna bake
these at 350 degrees for about 20
minutes while the muffins are in the
oven we're gonna move on to our monster
face paninis so first we're gonna crack
our eggs i am the king of breakfast
which is why i normally don't need to
use these little tricks but today i'll
do what i have to do so we're just gonna
add a little butter to our pan
whisk our eggs until they're nice and
light i do use a lot of butter and
breakfast
it's the most important meal of the day
so now that the butter's nice and melted
we're just going to add in our eggs
and keep them moving to make them nice
and fluffy as they cook so i'm just
making the egg into a square to make it
fit nicely onto the bread for our panini
just give it a nice little flip and the
eggs are ready for the panini i'm just
gonna take our two pieces of bread and
we're gonna start building our panini so
we're gonna add our egg now our eggs on
the bread we're gonna add a few pieces
of bacon i already have some cooked
bacon ready to go and then we're gonna
top our bacon with a little bit of
cheddar cheese dylan loves cheese he is
always looking for the perfect cheese
pull our sandwich is ready to go and
next step is we're gonna grill it on the
panini press so first we're gonna spray
our press and now we're gonna add our
sandwich we're gonna cook this for about
two minutes until it's golden brown and
crispy all right now that our sandwich
is golden brown and ready to go we're
gonna take it off the panini press and
start building our monster face first
thing we're gonna do for the monster
face is cut out circles of canadian
bacon for the eyes i don't think dylan's
ever had canadian bacon before so it's
another risk i'm gonna take but it's
delicious so can't go wrong with it now
we're just gonna cut little slices in
our canadian bacon so we could pop the
hard-boiled egg eyes through now this is
the part i'm worried about the most
because i don't think dylan likes
hard-boiled eggs but we are going to
find out today the eyes look okay i
think what gives eyes expression is the
eyebrows so once i add some angry
eyebrows onto there i think they'll look
a little better i think the eyebrows
give them a little more expression next
we are going to cut a red bell pepper
for the mouth and we're just going to
slice it into little strips and then
make it nice and spiky so it looks like
teeth and now we have our little mouth
last thing i'm gonna do is slice a few
pieces of kiwi just for the arms and
legs so it looks like a scary monster
what do you think that's a scary
sandwich now that we're finished with
our panini we're gonna check back in
with our muffins now that our muffins
are out of the oven we're going to fill
them with nutella just to give them a
special little treat dylan does have a
little sweet tooth but normally not in
actual meals now that our muffins are
done we're going to move on to our next
step which is a fruit smoothie so first
we're gonna add some frozen peaches some
frozen banana frozen chunks of pineapple
and two big handfuls of spinach dylan
will usually take about three sips of my
breakfast smoothie every morning so i
know he'll like it especially with the
green color green is his favorite color
so and now i'm just going to add a
little bit of coconut milk to blend it
all together and make a nice smoothie
all right now that our smoothie is all
blended and good to go we are going to
pour it into our glass and get our
garnishes ready i chose this smoothie
because every sunday morning we go to
the farmer's market as a family the
first stop at the farmer's market is i
get a green juice for myself and i might
get two sips in before dylan finishes
the rest of my green juice now that our
smoothie is in our glass we are going to
garnish it with little eyes made out of
bananas and blueberry so we're just
going to poke a little hole in the
banana with a glass straw so we could
fit our blueberry in there and we have
our little eyeball now that i have some
skewers i cut them down to size and
they'll fit perfectly in our glass and
there is our monster berry smoothie i
feel really good about this and i think
this might be his favorite part of the
entire breakfast
so the last thing we're going to make is
some fun fruit monsters so we're just
going to make a little monster mouth
we're going to cut our apple into slices
next we're gonna spread a little almond
butter inside the apple gonna put these
two together and now we're just gonna
put in some yogurt covered raisins to
look like little monster teeth for the
monster's eyes we're gonna put some
marshmallows on toothpicks with little
chocolate chips in the middle and
that'll also help it hold the whole
thing together now we have a monster
mouth next we're gonna make a monster
kiwi it's mostly eyes and teeth in
making monsters there's not much of an
art to it just try to make it look as
fun and scary as you can gonna do a few
slices of kiwi we're just gonna take our
first slice of kiwi put a little slice
of strawberry in the middle to make a
little tongue and now we're gonna take
our toothpick we're gonna add our
marshmallows and chocolate chips to make
our eyes for this little monster
toothpicks are pretty dangerous around
kids so you have to be a little careful
when making monsters out of food and now
we have our kiwi monster for our last
monster we're going to do orange with
some blueberry arms and legs and a
pineapple mohawk and he does love
mohawks i'm just taking blueberries and
putting them onto a toothpick and then
putting the toothpick into the orange so
now we have the body for our monster and
we're going to make a little pineapple
mohawk and stick that in and for the
monster's eyeball since it's not related
to the chocolate chip monsters we are
going to use a raisin for the eye now
that our monsters are assembled i'm
going to get everything together and
assemble our plate so first thing we're
going to do is move our sandwich over
that's going to be the center piece of
our plate with its little kiwi arms and
legs next we're going to add our
scariest muffin now we're going to put
our smoothie on the plate and i'm going
to try to stand up the cyclops now we'll
add our little fruit monsters and
breakfast deserved it is a real monster
party for breakfast i feel good i think
i do have a chance at redemption today
now let's go see what dylan thinks
better not let me down
monsters green's my favorite color i'm
going to try this first
i like it the alien i like robots
i like the blueberries
i choose bacon and eggs he looks funny i
think it's chocolate inside
what's your favorite thing you eat the
blueberries
i like this for breakfast let's bring in
the next dish all right
it's the beach i like the other one but
i don't know what this tastes like
it tastes like candy there's a bone on
it
i don't really like the pancakes
i like to fish eggs
i like it it's the season time did you
like the ocean plate or the monster
plate um
monster
daddy won good job dad thanks dude good
job dylan and great job jeremy i guess
we're tied now thanks so much for
watching and we'll see you next time bye
say bye bye
oh yes
you